my entire career in the military went
from excelling and on a extremely
promising path to retaliation and
ultimately being discharged with a
personality disorder
I lost my education benefits I lost
medical benefits any type of military
sexual trauma support groups there was
none of that
they had been sexually assaulted several
times I couldn't take it no more
and I knew this ship was getting ready
to leave so I went any wall I was not
gonna go out to see what these men and
deal with this every single day so I was
trying to get help for work and I was
told that they couldn't help me because
of my discharge that's when I started
learning more about other than honorable
discharges you're called wolf or
anything
there's other people that have the same
discharge that are committing suicide
that turn to drugs and alcohol and
frankly I'm at the point where it's like
I don't believe that they care about us
until they start fixing this problem